we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very interesting voicemail i
realized from looking at the email and
looking at comments about our vaccine
related stories
that this is actually a confusion that a
lot of folks have so listen to this then
i'll address it
david pakman big fan thank you
hey there i have a question about
the daily vaccine count yeah we've
addressed this but
i i can't quite find an answer when we
say
2.2 or 2.3 million people vaccinated
in one day does that mean
2.2 million shots given that day does
that mean
2.2 million people got their second dose
and now
are fully vaccinated so
i'm wondering if that how that count is
done
um again silly question if you could
just either answer it on the show you
don't have to put the message but
yeah no the message is a good one this
is this is a great question we are
talking about doses
okay so when we say 2.2 million doses
were given out
that's a combination of first and second
shots and
take the pfizer vaccine for example
which you have 21 days between shots
if today or let me i'll go backwards
imagine that 21 days ago
we gave out 800 000 pfizer shots and
then today
we give out 1.5 million pfizer shots
what that means is that today of the 1.5
million pfizer shots 800 000
if everything works right 800 000 were
second doses for people who got their
first dose 21 days ago
and then 700 000 would be first doses
for people who will get their second
dose
21 days from now right now the approved
vaccines in the united states are two
dose vaccines so when we say
2 million shots we are talking about 2
million total but that's only half of
the vaccination protocol for
uh each individual person they need a
second shot
soon it looks like the johnson johnson
vaccine is going to be approved that's a
one-shot
vaccine so in the future when we say oh
uh
we we did three million vaccines today
which would be
a great number that might be a number of
first and second doses of the pfizer
vaccine
a number of first and or second doses of
the modern vaccine
and then a bunch of johnson and johnson
doses which are
the one sole dose since it will be a one
dose so
we are talking about doses not people
totally vaccinated the new york times is
a good vaccine tracker
which will tell you total number of
doses
number of people who have received one
dose or more
and number of people who have received
full uh two two dose
regimens and these numbers are all going
to be going up
soon and we are going to be tracking it
we have a great bonus show for you today
we are going to talk about joe biden's
apparent snub of the saudi crown prince
mohammed bin salman i find it very
interesting and i kind of like the
direction biden is goading going
on not go he's not goading anybody going
on saudi relations
we will talk about facebook banning
australian users
from sharing or viewing news why are
they doing this
very interesting story and we will also
talk about
japan taking action on this issue of
social isolation
appointing a minister of loneliness to
help people who are home
alone this is not just because of the
pandemic this relates to issues that
have been happening culturally in japan
for some time
which we've been talking about all of
those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com